[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily the
murder of beauty queen tara grinstead he
said he brought the gloves after he
killed her here audio recording of ryan
duke's confession and custody
disagreements love triangles and a
murder for higher plot we look ahead to
the retrial of catherine meg manuel plus
i'm not looking for a little bit of
marijuana but i'm pretty sure you guys a
chaperone is probably going to be
disappointed in you did georgia officers
racially profile delaware state
university students but first x's johnny
depp and amber heard face off in court
johnny had the bottle inside of me
and was
shoving it inside of me over and over
again what you can expect to see during
amber herd's cross-examination law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to long time daily i'm
your host brian buckman amber heard's
direct examination is expected to resume
on monday and soon after an intense
cross-examination will follow co-host
terry austin joins us now to explain
what we could expect to see when
cross-examination begins
terry ryan the defamation trial against
amber heard began on april 11th and now
five weeks later depp's attorneys are
poised to begin herds cross-examination
in reality they began preparing for the
cross-examination the minute amber heard
took the stand there are numerous
inconsistencies in herds testimony but
depp's attorneys need to focus on two
main issues to win their defamation
claim
first they must demonstrate that the
december 2018 washington post article
was referring to johnny depp the aclu
representative terence doterry made that
perfectly clear
and isn't it true that ms heard's
advisors initially revised the draft to
remove
any reference
to ms heard's marriage or divorce i
recall a number of email communications
back and forth among
aclu personnel and ms heard's
attorneys
where they were
suggesting edits to the op-ed relating
to
matters covered in the nda
and then is it also true that there were
some
at the aclu
who expressed their belief
[Music]
that excising those references to
her marriage and divorce
from johnny depp
made
the op-ed less impactful correct
um it is correct that is correct
she was referring at least in part to
johnny depp correct
now based on my review of prior drafts
of the op-ed i knew that they were um
that she was referring to johnny depp in
her marriage
next depp's teen must demonstrate that
amber hurt is lying about the domestic
violence she claims depp committed
against her for years and if depp can
prove she's lying about one incident the
jury can easily infer that she's lying
about all of them heard's account of the
incident in australia was particularly
incredulous
is this the game table
yes it is okay and is this
based on your testimony is this where
you were were you on top of this table
yeah that he briefly got on top of me
um
and was pushing on my throat actually at
some point when i was on the table i had
forgotten about that
and
um
this though looks like it um
is after a lot of the stuff was cleaned
up because it didn't look quite like
this
okay and
did the table collapse
yes it did objection on our leading
sustained
what if anything happened to the table
the table collapsed underneath me um
when johnny
threw me into it and got on top of me or
or fell on top of me i i honestly don't
know which one
overall the cross-examination of amber
heard must be organized and methodical
in fact i would prepare a timeline to
serve as a demonstrative aide for the
jury once the jury visualizes the
magnitude of herds claims it will be
clear that if depp repeatedly beat her
she would have sustained serious
injuries over the course of their
relationship and there is absolutely no
evidence of that brian
thanks terry joining us today is l.a
county deputy public defender phillip
dube phillip amber heard claims that
depp had either hit punched push kicked
or sexually assaulted her on multiple
occasions now terry kind of led to this
but if she lied about one of those
incidents is the jury able to believe
that she lied about everything
absolutely one of the pattern jury
instructions throughout this country is
the uh falses in uno falses and omnibus
which basically tells the jury
that if you believe that a witness
or a party has lied about one material
aspect of the case you can disregard
everything that they've said because
they are not required to believe a word
that the witness says now on the other
hand they're not required to disregard
it it's discretionary so they could find
yeah maybe she told a couple of white
lies maybe she was a little hyperbolic
in her choice of words and her
characterizations and the over
dramatization of what occurred but we do
believe her in other aspects of her
testimony where she's going to have
trouble though is
showing how the
photographic the demonstrative evidence
belies how she physically appeared at
the time these photos were taken that
when you compare how she claims
everything went down to how it's
depicted in photos it just doesn't jive
so we'll see
in the end the jury might just instead
of giving them each 50 or 100 million
dollars give me to razzy yeah could be
terry based on your analysis of what
depth team needs to do during
cross-examination what would be your
first question
my first question would be what is it
that you actually are saying as far as
that washington post article is
concerned i'd start by playing the
testimony that we just saw of terence
doterry and i would say you heard what
he said there about the emails going
back and forth about deleting the
references to your marriage now are you
trying to tell this jury that that
article was not about johnny depp
remember you are under oath that's how i
would start that cross-examination yeah
good way to start from there you can go
in many different directions thank you
both for the update still ahead on law
and crime daily years after the murder
of a florida state university professor
an alleged accomplice will stay in trial
for the second time but first a group of
collegiate lacrosse players say they
were racially profiled during a traffic
stop in jordan still ahead we show you
the body camera footage
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily
delaware state university says members
of its women's lacrosse team were
racially profiled during a traffic stop
in georgia last month the hbcu released
a statement reading in part quote we do
not intend to let this or any incident
like it pass idly by we have video we
have allies all this comes after an
april 20th traffic stop in georgia when
the team's bus was stopped after a game
on the road at first officers told the
bus driver a georgia state law was
violated after that the university's
president says the officers attempted to
intimidate students into confessing they
had illegal drugs or paraphernalia body
camera footage of the incident was
released shortly after
we're gonna check y'all's luggage
okay
if there is anything in y'all's luggage
we're probably gonna find it
okay i'm not looking for a little bit of
marijuana but i'm pretty sure you guys
the chaperone is probably going to be
disappointed in you if
we find any
you guys were on a lacrosse team correct
so if there is something in there that
is questionable please tell me
now because if we find it
guess what we're not going to be able to
help you
okay you guard in the state of georgia
marijuana is still illegal in the state
of georgia
okay anything that anything that you can
put marijuana in maybe a device where
you smoke it maybe something that you
would weigh it like a set of scales
um anything
okay um
if there's nothing then i'm thankful to
make my job a lot easier we're going to
get this done and we'll have you guys on
your way
following the incident the liberty
county sheriff released a statement
saying officers did not know who was
inside the bus because the vehicle's
height and tinted windows the sheriff
also noted nothing illegal was found
during the search
philip real quick what's a pretextual
stop and was this legal or an illegal
stop by the police
well the short answer is
constitutionally even if it was
pretextual it's a big so what it doesn't
matter legally as long as they truly
pulled them over for a moving violation
and according to uh the officers they
pulled that bus over because it was
riding in the wrong lanes i think they
were limited to the far too right lanes
and traffic yes it's not you know a
federal case or a serious matter but it
is a traffic infraction and probable
cause to pull the bus over
my understanding though that they had
drug sniffing canines that alerted once
the bus pulled over if that's the case
constitutionally it's not a search they
do not need a warrant it's probable
cause to search
and unfortunately they didn't find
anything but does that mean it's
unconstitutional or illegal
the short answer is it could be
if these kids were all held and detained
beyond the time necessary to investigate
and cite the driver for that stupid
little moving violation then yes it
became a prolonged detention and their
civil rights were violated under section
1983 for which that claim could be
compensable yeah now terry as both a
parent and a lawyer what is your
reaction to these young women uh
being stopped like this and are there
any legal recourses
you know it is very difficult to watch
these young women being stopped and
searched and having all of their luggage
exposed like that and i'm sure they
didn't know what to think about it from
a legal perspective obviously philip is
right about that but if those dogs were
searching and they saw something on the
outside i don't think they had a right
to go on the inside and subject these
women to an unreasonable search and
seizure in my opinion yeah and i'm
wondering if one why were the the drug
sniffing dogs even brought and two if
they didn't find anything what are they
detecting still a lot of questions a lot
of answers to be resolved in this case
and we'll follow it as it continues an
update now on the american basketball
player being held in russia officials
now say wnba star brittany griner's
release has been extended by one month
greiner has been held in russia since
february after being accused of drug
smuggling the u.s government says she is
being wrongfully detained some
supporters speculate greiner is being
purposely held amidst the russia ukraine
conflict this week a russian court ruled
greiner will be detained until at least
june 18th
coming up on law and crime daily
defendant ryan duke tells investigators
what led up to the murder of beauty
queen tara grimstad plus we take a
closer look at the murder of law
professor dan marco and the twisted web
of suspects involved
[Music]
welcome back we're looking ahead now to
the retrial of catherine mcbanoa a woman
accused of being the go-between in the
murder-for-hire plot of a florida state
university professor
dan markell was shot and killed in 2014
at the time he and wife wendy adelson
were in a custody battle prosecutors say
wendy's brother charlie adelson
recruited his then girlfriend catherine
mcbanoa to help murder markel mcbanwalk
contacted the father of her children
sigfredo garcia who later enlisted luis
rivera officials say garcia rivera then
shot and killed markel in 2019 garcia
and mcbanoa were tried as co-defendants
garcia was convicted and given life in
prison without parole but the jury was
unable to reach a verdict for mcmanual
last month charlie allison was arrested
and charged with first-degree murder
conspiracy to commit murder and
solicitation of murder meg bandwa faces
the same three charges jury selection in
her retrial is expected to begin on
monday state with the law and crime
network for gavin to gather coverage of
the trial
terry does charlie adelson's uh supposed
connection as a financer of this murder
create a new level to this charge in
these cases for mcbaniwa could he
testify against her in her case
oh he definitely could testify against
her and i think now that he's been
arrested he's going to be
pointing the finger away from him and
towards mcmahon there's no question
about it and we already know that the
other two defendants have already been
convicted and so he is going to try to
get her convicted and try to save
himself he's got these serious charges
as you mentioned the first degree murder
conspiracy to commit murder solicitation
of murder that's very serious so he's
going to do everything he can to protect
himself and to point the finger
everywhere else but him and his family
yeah what's the old saying follow the
money might do that just with him uh
phillip angel's question we ask it of
everyone who do you think has the
advantage in a retrial and based on that
who do you think will win this second
trial against meg banoa
well the short answer it depends absent
a grant of immunity for charlie if he
takes the stand and testifies against
her i think she's dead in the water
because that's an additional missing
piece of the evidence that they didn't
have at the first trial but on retrial
if they don't give him immunity charlie
is going to take the fifth he's also
jointly charged or separately indicted
no lawyer is going to let him take the
stand so i think the prosecution's case
is just as weak and as shaky as it was
in the first go-around but again if they
give him immunity she's dead in the
water yeah but that takes a little bit
of time as well with this trial on
monday maybe they don't get their ducks
in a row uh to give him immunity for
that opportunity so we'll have to stay
tuned to law and crime network to see
that because that's going to be exciting
as to whether he takes the stand when we
come back defendant ryan duke confesses
to the murder of tara grinstead here at
duke's first-hand account of the murder
and why he says he was inside tara
grinstead's house
[Music]
welcome back as week one comes to a
close in the tara grinstead murder trial
we're hearing from defendant ryan duke
himself in 2017 duke and bo dukes were
charged in connection to grinstead's
murder the pair are not related but were
friends at the time of grinstead's
disappearance the small town teacher and
beauty queen went missing from her
georgia home in 2005. for years the
caves had few leads until the podcast up
and vanish reignited an interest in the
case after to lease both dukes and beau
dukes were arrested prosecutors say ryan
duke confessed to killing grinstead
after he broke into her home later both
dukes helped burn her body in a pecan
orchard duke's attorneys later said he
was under the influence of drugs during
the confession on thursday jurors heard
audio clips of ryan duke's 2017
confession where he explained why he
entered grinstead's home
i used to break into people's houses
just to steal money i was a drug addict
i i've been drinking i was high i don't
remember everything clearly okay but
i was stealing from a purse and
she
snuck up on me and
i hit her i didn't mean to purely
reactionary but
in my brain
i mean i didn't know what else to do
that's the only reason i didn't come
forward before
i just
i can't lie i can't live with myself i'm
so sick of this stuff i mean if you
don't have a relationship or there was
something else there that's okay she was
she had relationships with lots of other
people including other students that's
not a secret i'm not sure i didn't i
never even had a conversation
[Music]
after jurors heard ryan do's confession
prosecutors questioned a lead
investigator about the police interview
he explained what ryan duke said
happened after grinstead was killed and
how the famed latex glove came to be
found on her property
when did the defendant indicate he
brought the glove to tara's home
he said he brought the gloves after he
killed her he said he killed her then
left the house in a rush went back to
his house to gather a quilt and the
gloves to then come back to the crime
scene which is again when he made the
phone call on his way back to the house
and then went to the house
towards the end of the video portion we
hear you discussing going
out there or him taking you somewhere
where is it that you wanted him to go
with you the orchard where they dumped
the body where he dug the body the first
time then they took the body to the
secondary location
and before i move on let's talk about
that the information that you've just
said where he dumped the body and then
they took it to a secondary location can
you tell us what you mean by that from
what ryan duke told you sure he said
when he took her out to the orchard he
put her into the actual into the pecan
orchard um and that the body stayed
there for several days before they went
back out he and bo went back out there
to the
orchard and then he that's when beau
found out and saw the body for the first
time and then they moved the body from
there together to the deeper into the
woods to the pine tree area then went
back to the shed and got the loads of
wood
from the shed that was located just near
the entrance as you go in and then
proceeded to burn about
philip factually speaking does dude's
confession make sense with the evidence
that we've seen so far at trial
oh yes you know this young man was not
on a magical mystery ride from quaaludes
and hallucinogenics he was clearly quite
clear and level-headed he wasn't labile
or dysregulated in how he recounted what
occurred his starting point remember is
that he broke in looking for drug money
he happens to be a drug addict the house
appeared to be ransacked her she was not
there
so you know in the end for him the the
drugs appeared to be a real truth serum
and he had too much detail to say that
he was on a magical mystery ride of
intoxication so i think it's a very very
damaging confession and if memory serves
me he also confessed prior to that at a
bar at a party just sort of informally
to friends and attendees at this
get-together so he told the same story
twice so unless he was under the
influence of the same drug twice and
gave the same account you know bad luck
but otherwise i think he's in jeopardy
exactly now terry duke's defense says
that he was under the influence when he
gave this confession his body language
his tone his story everything about him
does that read to you that he was under
the influence
you know what brian when i listened and
i looked at that confession it does not
look like he's under the influence of
narcotics or any other drug for that
matter you know as a jury you have to
listen to the content of what they're
saying but you also have to watch their
mannerisms and he did admit that he was
tired but beyond that his speech was
clear he was lucid he sat up he looked
in the eyes of those who were
questioning him and he described the
murder with great detail so i don't
think that he in any way was under the
influence so i think the jury is going
to take that confession for what it's
worth yeah well we'll see what the jury
does with that confession philip terry
thank you very much and thank you for
joining us here at law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as you discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you